if one less kid can grow up without
having to hide who they are along the
way or without having to believe that
who they love is something that will
make them lonely
then everything i went through will have
been worth it
if i can help somebody's journey move
along by being my authentic self whether
that's in interviews whether that's on
tv whether that's
in music i feel like
that's now my responsibility i'm not
burdened by any stretch it's a it's a
responsibility i hold very dear to my
heart
i've had messages from young guys young
girls older people
any kind of situation being like
you helped me come to terms with who i
am you helped me come to my family
and that to me is like
magic that to me is like
that's what i base my success on it's
those messages
[Music]
how does it feel to be releasing a
sophomore album and putting your 100
honest authentic self into that music i
feel incredibly proud that i'm in a
position where i can put my
you know authentic self out there and i
can be
proud and you know show display that
kind of bravery and courage to to try
and encourage other people you know when
i was younger i think pride to me was
like a party as i've gotten older i
completely understand what pride
represents so at this point in your life
what does pride mean to you when i got
into music that's when i really
discovered
my sense of pride and i was like pride's
not just like you say the party and the
kind of the colors and the flags
it's about change and it's about
positivity and it's about embracing who
you are but i've got to say there is
change happening all the time and it's
so encouraging to see and it fills me
with pride